because i remember rebecca and your kids
were on stage like went on at you know
when
celebrating and i remember feeling i
don't really
like i don't have a photographic memory
but the sense that i got was i remember
going
oh he's got a great family
i really honestly the joy in the your
kids you know
face and just the joy that we felt
watching it
was just a uh a memorable moment let's
back up a second
you have a very clear recollection of
that fight night
no i don't yeah well we have video
footage of
you reacting to bisping winning oh all
right i need to
see this i won't look for it but you
keep going yeah yeah
okay so sit down bobby relax
this is gonna be really awkward a force
field in between you and me don't worry
i'm retired okay what is it what is it
sit down this is gonna get really
awkward for you okay okay so
we had it we had our entire family over
and your brother and i you were acting
like the oracle you said there was not a
chance and [ __ ] hell
that he could ever or anyone and he
wonders why i won't give him a picture
of the comedies
and i remember this and then your
brother and i and gilbert we said
i wouldn't i wouldn't speak so fast
we had you man the whole night we had
you we had and then
he knocks him out and you
ran to three different bedrooms came
back with your tail between your legs
and you were in total disbelief
do you remember that you said there was
not a chance and thanks bobby
i thought we were i know right there bud
hold on i thought i don't know because
it was podcasting i don't recall it was
i don't recall it like that we have
videos like we're brothers now
yeah yeah she's made all right i'll save
the video and we'll post this yeah yeah
yeah
here we go wait hold on rewind it rewind
it remind it remind it oh wait wait wait
is this going to embarrass me no yes yes
yes all right bobby's like i had a
thousand on rockhold
a thousand dollars on the rockhold then
didn't you look
[Laughter]
that's great
look at that wow look at gilbert and i
were excited
well thank you very much everybody
that's showing excitement
and i apologize to the one person that's
disappointed about me
i love you you did it for your family
oh hold on hold on be honest be honest
be honest
you guys recreated this recently no no
film this recently
did you know i was coming you thought
let's play 2016. june 14.
well that's great thank you
what with this guy of course i got a
suspicious mind cause he's from san
diego here's
here's the thing all right let's let's
regroup
yeah okay we watch every fight we watch
every one of your fights okay that's
that's number one i've
had one for a long time okay i know but
we did
right and i have to be honest with you
okay that was very real
i'll tell you why because luke rockhold
is from santa cruz or whatever right
and he skateboards i'm from san diego
right so i feel like he's like
you skateboard i used to all right no i
was going to say so he's from santa cruz
you're from san diego nowhere near each
other
any skateboards you don't he's
as wide as become as asian as the cops
i'm failing to see how like you guys are
boys and you're connected
how many times has he driven true
and smog that's true done the podcast
how many times let me ask you this
michael
let me ask you this how many times does
luke [ __ ] face rockhold done my podcast
none
ask him all right all right that's true
that's number two true number and also
i'm sweating
here's here's the second thing okay is
is that
sure 2016 right right
that was the night where i laid down in
bed and i became a michael bisping fan
all right that was the night that was it
yes yes all right i watched your season
of the ultimate
yeah yeah i didn't even know what that
was yes
you were a little behind i was a little
behind so what i'm saying is is that
okay yeah
at the time that's a real man
that's a real shut the [ __ ] up shut the
[ __ ] up everybody all right
at the time right i was rooting for luke
rockhold
and at the time when you beat him open
your eyes i am opening my eyes i'm asian
you [ __ ] face
right yeah that's as quiet as they go
right right and um and at the time
i was rooting for him and when he you
knocked him out it was such a shock to
my system
but then i was reborn like a phoenix wow
the catalyst and i and i and i was
convinced
from that day forward right that you
were the guy
okay first you think when you fought
george's year that i wanted him to win
i went likely no well come on everybody
likes george let's be honest he's a
sweetheart i'd see here's the thing when
i met kalylah
i had stopped watching ufc for
a long time a long time a long time i i
couldn't even have a conversation
with you and so the george seemed pierre
years
i was in houston when he lost to max
matt sarah because i was because the
jordan peel you know who directed get
out yes so the ufc for
one night hired me and jordan peele to
do some sort of comedy thing
at some red carpet event for them right
and they never asked us again but it was
me
and jordan were in houston when we saw
george
st pierre lose to matt sarah and i
remember
everyone was shocked and i was so like
not involved that i didn't even know
that that was a big deal
yeah right it's when i met her on tinder
do you always have tinder and she was a
big fan
i slowly got back into the ufc right
so for me you know i wasn't a george
saint peter okay okay hold on
let me just stop you right there i'm
going to give you some advice bobby
i don't need advice well i'm going to
give you some and you're going to hear
this and you're going to go oh
interesting yeah i'll take that on board
okay next time you're with a fighter
right and
you know you're clearly making my
fighting
ability the the conversation piece
and you talk about a former opponent of
mine yes don't
intro the conversation about the
opponent who beat
me by saying oh yeah i remember watching
him get his [ __ ] ass kicked one time
and then he went on to beat you
a roundabout slap in the face that was
weird that was kind of weird yeah
it's like oh yeah yeah i remember you
got beat up that one
they got his ass kicked all right you're
right you're right
i mean just say wow the greatest of all
time george said pierre he was
unstoppable
yeah that's that would have been better
don't go i remember when he got his
[ __ ] ass kicked
i've gotta show a little fat guy max yo
to me
all right right it's a backhander i'm
just learning but i always saw that as a
fluke wasn't it like a spinning back
fist or something
no no he called you but you know okay so
i want to say this okay kind of flinky
but
yeah i did not go to journalism school
okay
all right i've never went to college
okay i'm just telling you that i'm just
like this little weird
korean fella you know i mean in 1995 i
walked by a comedy club
and i signed up for an amateur night i
have no is that true yeah i have no
skills
whatsoever and i went up and i see it
she could i have i don't know anything
nothing right so um in terms of talking
to people
and being a journalist or an interviewer
i don't know what i'm doing you don't
need to be a joke i know my my point is
is that you know
um i think that um you know i apologize
it's okay it's okay it's okay i don't i
don't i i i want to
i'm trying to try to make you a better
person i know i want to do it i'm trying
to make you i want to learn
okay i i [ __ ] it up right there's two
things i [ __ ] up right
i [ __ ] up the luke rockhold thing
right and i [ __ ] up the [ __ ] george
st pierre thing right
and and i'm learning as i go okay and i
apologize
okay apology not necessary okay let's
talk about fully accepted
let's talk about saturday again okay so
do you think